-How can men --
You know, again,
you've gone through this
so many times,
but how are men most helpful
as allies in a time like this?
-Well, I think
it's even more helpful
to realize men's stake in it
You know?
Because, actually, if you look
at the cause of male deaths,
speeding and violence, and
you know, you add them all up,
the Women's Movement and the
dissolution of gender role
means that you would have abou
five more years of life to live.
This is not bad, is it?
-Yeah.
-Who else can make that offer?
[ Laughter ]
-I would love that.
Yeah, that would be wonderful.
-And also, getting to know
your own children.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, because the system,
as it is, means that,
frequently, men are
estranged from their children,
and men get to be whole people
by being active in the hom
and raising
or being raised
to raise children
just like we get to be
whole people by being
active outside the home.
-You've started
a couple magazines.
You've helped start
Do you feel like
there's still a role --
because obviously,
it's a very scary time
for print journalism --
but for sort of
vibrant journalism to brin
attention to these issues?
Are you worried at all
about the fact that
there are less platforms
for people --
a young version --
well, less perspective.
[ Laughter ]
But somebody starting out
their career now,
do you feel like there
are enough ways for them
to have the impact that you had?
-Yes, because online, you know
is huge.
And magazines are still
very important.
But what worries me more
is the lack of fact-checking
-Mm-hmm.
-And I think the only way
we're gonna get
really accurate facts
is to pay as we do for
newspapers and magazines
at least a little something.
-Right.
-Because advertising
is always gonna to, you know
the biggest number of eyeballs
which it how we got
the President.
-Yeah.
-If there weren't advertising,
we wouldn't have had that show
that was like
watching a roadside accident
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
-And it's very --
'Cause the one thing about
roadside accidents is they don't
show commercials during them
which is very nice.
[ Laughter ]
You have this -- make this
very interesting observation
in the book that men have an
issue with women in power
because it brings them
back to their childhood.
Because often,
the last time they saw a woman
of authority was school
when they were very young.
-No, I think as long as we'r
all raised by women --
women, too -- but women --
We have, of course,
a little self-correction
because we realize
we can do other things.
But for men, I think,
really the last time they sa
an authoritative woman --
really, an authority
over them -- they were a child
and they feel regressed
when they see it.
I mean, otherwise,
I can't explain why
my grown-up male journalis
friends say things like,
"I cross my legs
whenever I see Hillary Clinton."
What is that about?
[ Laughter ]
You know, "She reminds me
of my wife outside --"
I mean, you know, intelligen
men say these crazy things
-Yeah. Maybe we're just
not that intelligent.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no.
No, I'm not going there.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you -- Seeing this field
of candidates --
Obviously, it's a very
diverse field right now.
There's a lot of candidates.
Are you optimistic,
moving forward?
How do you feel?
-Yeah, I am opt--
It is the most diverse field
of candidates,
and my position is,
I would work my heart out
for any one of them.
-Yeah.
-It's character that matters
and they all have so much
better character than --
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But I do think that
we have a problem of looking up.
You know, we have
a case of the "shoulds" --
"What should I do?"
-Yeah.
-And then we don't --
We become uncertain,
but when we look at each other
we know what to do.
-All right.
Well, I hope we all
do the right thing
when the time comes.
And thank you so much
for being here.
It's such an honor to have you
-No, thank you.
-Gloria Steinem, everybody